[Applause]
happy thursday everyone
cats off today
but julie banderas is sitting in for her
which definitely increases the average
blood alcohol content for the panel yep
we went from point zero five to the
point of no return
pete heggseth is here
good to see he's relaxing his dimples
and took some time off from parenting
he has so many children he and his wife
just bought a new house
[Laughter]
so
big news a republican has flipped a
house seat in the deep blue south texas
that's scary to dems who thought the
only seat flipping would be in a
gender-neutral bathroom
is this an indicator of a coming red
wave
maybe and it's got nothing to do with
the tampon shortage
a tasteless sexist would say
they're terrible
it's absolutely terrible i don't stand
for that kind of humor
but let's ask the folks at the view
which no one has ever said in the
history of the universe
is there a red wave coming
the red wave is coming republicans are
going to win the midterms short of
something unforeseen that i cannot
predict predict now you don't know that
you don't know
let's wait and see where the people
voted
yeah you know what i love about the view
it reminds people every day not to eat
lead paint chips
[Laughter]
but you got to remember joy behar
thought that her going on a sex strike
would make men change their minds
and they did to vote republican
look at republican myra flores
she won that seat in south texas the
first win there in 150 years that's a
long time it's like two julie banderas
or a half a joe biden
she flipped an 84 hispanic district red
and i bet it's because the liberal
policies from washington are tearing our
community apart
but liberal policies from washington are
tearing our community apart
as a wife of a border patrol agent i
pray for his safety now more than ever
we must secure our borders and keep our
families safe
well she's not only smart but attractive
who does she remind me of in that regard
i remember when that was taken
floor seat was previously held by a
democrat who stepped down to become a
lobbyist after realizing he'd lose in a
red wave so he took the easy way out
like when i hide behind tyrus to avoid
kill meat in the hallway
and she's now the first congresswoman
ever to be born in mexico
so i'm sure aoc must find this historic
first pretty empowering so let's go to
her for comment
[Applause]
and then you hear that elon musk voted
for flores which prompted democrat
congressman jamal bowman to accuse musk
of supporting white supremacy
yeah that's logic vote for a woman of
color who's born in mexico and that
makes you racist
jamal got any dumber you know he could
be on the view
floor's earned an endorsement from
governor greg abbott and guess who's
trailing him in the governor's race by
20 freaking points
yes go to your screen go to your screen
right now and scratch scratch what does
that smell like to you
viewers
loser
we would have accepted axe body spray
this guy couldn't win a coin toss if he
got to call both sides
meanwhile biden's approval rating with
hispanic and latino voters sits in the
mid-20s that's the worst of any ethnic
group
geraldo's mustache is more popular
and for good reason joe's embracing of
hard-left policies has abandoned decent
people of every pigment in every race
they said he was a uniter and now people
of all races think that captain poo-poo
pants sucks
[Applause]
and it undermines everything racist dems
have been saying for years about
changing demographics they thought
mexicans would be dupes for their hard
left tripe how bigoted is that a lot of
other states are heading toward
increasing diversification toward
demographic changes that mean
a less red state future for them i
really think because of demographic
changes in this country i think that the
democratic party is going to win texas
moving forward and the democratic party
is going to be in power for the next 30
40 years texas have had on this sort of
long-term project of of trying to take
some red states across the sun belt and
flip them blue as demographic changes
are taking place there and the
demographic change that's happening in
america right now gives the upper hand
to democrats
wow it's almost like they are dare i say
it white supremacists in their thinking
the assumption that every brown person
will fall in line and vote for crap if
they were bribed with free stuff dems
are like saying you know sure they're
pro-life and religious but give them
free dental and will own their asses
but they forgot that hispanics aren't as
progressive as the white liberal assumes
it's why you only hear clueless whites
using the phrase latinx it's awful hard
as well
to get
latinx vaccinated as well why
they're worried that they'll be
vaccinated and deported
all right gramps
fact is
you don't have to do much
he really is a godsend in fact his
mexicans are just like anybody else they
don't want to be victims of crime that's
why many left mexico they want to afford
gas and food and drink water that
doesn't double as a laxative
but the left wants them to drop a
hundred grand on an electric car and
then eat crickets
also unlike the left they go to church
they believe in god they're pro-life
they think family's a good thing they're
basically eisenhower republicans
they understand the hierarchy of need
see the little chart there that in life
stuff like food and family and energy
that comes first and that's a far cry
from pronouns statute toppling and
insurrection porn
the least important thing on that chart
self-actualization
we don't even know what that is
but the republican party gets this that
we're all united by common sense a
working knowledge of home depot as well
as the pleasures of a fine tequila
but the dams thanks to their delusional
embrace of wokism have it backwards
here's the left's hierarchy of needs
call everyone racist
blame everything on america
oppression
never babe
here's
here's joe's hierarchy of needs
blame other people for failures
bail out hunter
watch murder she wrote
find ice cream
nap
it's actually not bad
no wonder the dems chase a pointless
that's because without structure work or
family you end up with moronic
platitudes you will own nothing but so
what you'll have 64 genders to choose
from and the government government will
mail you a crack pipe
that's the hunter plan
hell the last time a democrat made
something they became a republican
so who is myra flores
i'm sure by november she'll be the new
face of white supremacy
or for my spanish-speaking friends at
home la nueva cara de la supremacia
blanca
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests
author
author of the children's book why is
mommy napping at 2 p.m
fox news anchor julie banderas
i thought you were going to her i was
like she wrote a book how nice he's so
patriotic the statue of liberty once hit
on him co-host of fox and france weekend
and author of the new book battle for
the american mind pete headset
and a brand new guest she knows
campaigning like i know complaining tag
strategies vp and former director press
communications for trump tree election
campaign aaron perrini
and
he needs a steamroller to iron his shirt
so my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champions
julie uh what is your nationality your
last name is banderas well actually my
last name is bidwell banderas is made up
yep that's true you heard it here first
you appropriated banderas is made up
because it's a long story but my last
name is bidwell but i'm part colombian
part british oh interesting yes
well i'm glad i asked i'm a mix you're
you're my mess is what you
are a hot mess are you surprised by her
win
no she lives in texas yeah i mean they
don't like they like legal hispanics
there yes so they like her yes and as a
legal hispanic and the daughter of
migrant workers she is a perfect example
of why republicans are definitely going
to be taking over texas because they
don't want to see illegals in there
anymore and she's a perfect example of
why democrats should probably just
retire at this point
now you this is your this is your uh
wheelhouse just coined that phrase do
you see a red wave how do you how many
seats do you see
well it's it's kind of hard to say i
think you're probably looking at more
like 40-ish seats that'll flip you're
not going to see like a 60 70 80 number
because redistricting right there aren't
as many middle-of-the-road seats where
there are soft dems for republicans to
flip the seats there is going to be a
red wave i fully believe that kevin
mccarthy is the next speaker of the
house i think the senate is very much in
play but not as much as the house i
think the house you're you're like 95
percent chance we're flipping that the
senate it's a tougher map see that that
to me then is not a red wave at all that
should be expected when you're out of
power
you're supposed to win right that
happens happens when trump was in then
the democrats rose up when obama was in
the republicans
they i mean if they can't get 50 60
seats they're blowing a big opportunity
i would think and i'm no expert
well
that's fair but it's also changing no
greg you are an expert well all right no
greg you are an expert thank you
in some things yes
not many i mean political math
that's up to you whether or not you want
to say you're an expert on that but i
can say that it's going to be a tougher
road to get to 50 or 60. just because i
mean you have to look at i don't factor
in the redistricting yeah you gotta look
at like you look at jersey you look at
new york do i have to no okay
pete congratulations on the new book
thank you very much
uh
thank you
i noticed that you quote tucker but not
me and i'm not even in the index which
means i'm not in the book it's a family
book greg i can't your material is not
usable
it's always about family with you isn't
it
pipe down all right pete
yay or nay red wave yay on the red wave
if you think about the senate map and
correct me if i'm wrong 2022 means
senators that were elected six years ago
2016 was a good year for trump a lot of
republicans brought in you're defending
those
seats so there's not as many democrat
pickups to be had on the map so i don't
think that's indicative of whether or
not it'll be a wave the house is more
indicative of that in that it's up every
two years maya flores i mean you look at
that her ad i'm the wife of a border
patrol agent
uh and who lives this every single day
and i love what you said it is
inherently racist to assume that a
certain skin color will v vote a certain
way uh and as you said i believe you
said captain poo poo pants yes
uh
i'm as good as spidwell party
will be finding that out when you
totally de-prioritize the things that
matter in everyone's everyday lives uh
you even if your party's gone hard left
which they have voters end up rejecting
that just ask the da's in san francisco
and los angeles that's a very good point
what do you think tyrus is it racist to
have voted for her
yeah of course it is yes
they said so several times she's the new
face of white supremacy oh it's it's
they needed one and
larry elder i mean larry elder did a
good job for a while there larry did his
part but his heart just wasn't in it no
he wasn't he tried
he tried you know so hopefully it's a
friendlier more focused white
supremacist party i think we're opening
up to women and mexican women yeah and
us blacks so it's really it's a whole
new white supremacist exactly
shocking kind of miss the old days but
um
i just always just drives me crazy when
they say and the latinos have a problem
with the president who doesn't yeah
which
which group is he above
20 yeah there's not one no one's
claiming him yeah yeah that's the one
thing funny about white people
you will sell each other out you will
not stick together
like
biden's going down with the ship and the
white people are acting like he's having
fun on a ride at the beach no one's
going in they're like oh look at him huh
yeah that is so true
yeah he's like that one stray sock guys
are cold-blooded man
[Laughter]
yeah oh well
we will see shall we
i just coined that phrase as well
up next dems let thugs go free as they
say protection for me not for thee hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else